howdy Gotham City miss me  I'm going to play this amazing practical  joke on Gotham and I need your help  took to it Joker's got cyborg he  controls technology now he's turning  Gotham against us scarecrow silver  Banshee and Grundy all working together  on the same night each of them a  powerful enemy in their own right why  follow the Joker Batman we're back to  the Dark Ages here I know it's a  computer virus we're trying to hack it  now Oh  Grundy you big galoot Batman can't win  Grundy coming for you Batman Red Robin  cover me from above Nightwing arrow cut  them off  why settle the Gotham when we could rule  the entire world stop this now Joker I  can't hear you  you can't beat me in my own game  Batman unlimited monster mayhem look for  it on DVD and digital HD quick selfie